Optimal, minimal. At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
You posted a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This episode is brought
to you by trunk club.
There are two types of men out there.
You know who you are,
guides who love shopping for clothes,
but a short on time category a and
those of you who hate it. Category B,
I am in the latter category.
My fashion sense is also
probably somewhere between
homeless and confused with a
dash of lazy added in either way,
you can take heart and I've used trunk
club now and have found some of my
favorite pieces of clothing that make me
look a lot better than I would be able
to handle on my own and there
are many reasons for that,
but you can get clothing that fits
perfectly and looks amazing without ever
stepping into a store. Again, thanks
to trunk club and they make it very,
very easy and the clothing is
handpicked by a personal stylist,
your own personal stylist.
All you have to do is go to trunk
club.com forward slash Tim typing your
measurements,
share your likes and dislikes.
They'll pick your clothes from more than
80 top brands and ship them right to
your door. You keep what you like,
you send back what you don't.
If you don't like any of it, send
it all back. It doesn't matter.
And Trunk Club is not
a subscription service.
This is what appealed to
me among many other things.
I didn't want to constantly be getting
dinged by things or have to deal with the
headache of constantly getting boxes.
It's not a subscription service.
Shipping is always free and you have
five days to try on the clothes. So,
uh, couple of points here.
Number one, get started today.
Go to trunk club.com forward slash
Tim, try it out. You get premium,
close expert advice, no work, no risk.
That is a winning Combo.
And I have found some of my favorite
espadrilles shoes from them. Bright Green.
Uh, I do like the color
green and they actually work.
I've had so many compliments on the
shoes and more people ask me where I got
them than any other pair of shoes I've
ever had and more shirts I kept ended up
keeping about. I would say three quarters
of my box, which I did not expect to do,
so go to trunk club.com forward slash Tim,
check it out.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many, many years.
I absolutely love audio books in there.
One of my favorite ways to
pass the time when I travel,
I'm on the road all the time and audible
allows me to consume many more books
than I possibly could otherwise I have
to audio books to recommend right off the
bat. The first is perhaps my favorite
audio book of all time and it's the only
audiobook I've wanted to
listen to twice in a row.
The graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
It's amazing and you will thank me.
There are a few different versions.
I like the version that
Neil narrates himself,
one of the most soothing
voices of all time.
The second book is
vagabonding by Rolf Potts.
P o t t s which had a huge impact on my
life and formed the basis for a lot of
what would later become
the four hour workweek.
So go to audible.com forward slash Tim
and you can choose one of these two books
or any of many,
many other options that could be books,
magazines and much more as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can also access a free 30 day trial.
Just go to audible.com forward slash
Tim you can't make more time but you can
make the most of it.
So turn your travel or your commute
into something more with a free trial at
audible.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim to
start now and get your free 30 day trial.
Ladies and germs,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world
class performers of all types,
whether they are military strategists,
super athletes,
business icons or anything in between.
Really to tease out the habits,
routines, favorite books, tips and tricks
you can test and apply in your own life.
And this episode was a real treat.
If you enjoyed my episodes
with Seth Goden, Noah Kagan,
any episode that really gets
into the nitty gritty details,
then you are going to love this one.
It is a conversation with [inaudible]
and I'll spell that for you.
So m a,
N C H,
a I N K and I tried the English today
and you can find them on Twitter,
on social at [inaudible] and all places.
He was introduced to me
by Brian Koppelman, very,
very accomplished artists,
screenwriter, producer, cocreator
of the hit show, billions and a,
a very,
very long filmography.
And when I asked Brian what I should dig
into with some, and he said many things,
but among others, his disc
quote, his discipline and rigor,
carefulness of his approach
in all aspects of life.
He's in incredible physical condition.
He's super careful by
fan financial security.
He kept tutoring after
getting a three book deal.
He's a detailed planner and
an artist of high order,
more disciplined and organized
and businesslike than
almost any artist I've met.
So who is Soman? Well.
His debut fiction series,
the school for good and evil has
sold more than a million copies,
well over a million copies.
Been translated into 25
languages across six continents.
Been in New York Times bestseller for
30 weeks and will soon be a film from
universal pictures with Soman cowriting.
The screenplay is a graduate of Harvard
University and Columbia University's MFA
film program after which he began his
career as a screenwriter for film and TV.
He was recently named to the out 100 and
has received the $100,000 circle grant
and the Sun Valley Writers Fellowship,
both for debut writers.
He's also an incredible tennis player,
which we will dig into and there are a
lot of parallels in a lot of between the
two, what we talked about, his obsession
with Disney and we cover so much ground.
I think you guys will really enjoy
this episode. So pay attention,
get a notebook ready and please enjoy
my conversation with Soman Chimani.
Soman welcome to the show.
Thanks so much for having me.
I am sitting here with a s a set of
questions and exploratory bullets and each
one of these could be explored for,
I would say an hour or
two, I would guess. So we,
we may need around too at some point.
But I'm getting ahead of myself.
Let's start at the mutual
connection that we have.
How do you know the incredible
Brian Koppelman and for
you people who don't know
that name, he is a
polymath. He is a writer.
He cowrote rounders.
The illusion is I think the illusionist
he co produced and is cocreator of
billions. This a new hit show,
which I'm absolutely in love with.
But how do you know Brian?
Well,
it started I think because in my
twenties I'd come out of film school at
Columbia and I had gone straight to London
and had been working on a movie over
there for a couple of years and that
was supposed to be my sort of hot shot
debut and, and all that stuff.
And um, it ultimately fell apart.
And so I came back to New York when I
was like, you know, 25 or 26 baroque,
a quarter million dollars in debt
from college and film school.
And I didn't know how to make money,
so, you know, I didn't know what to do.
And luckily a friend saved me and
introduced me to a couple clients and,
and told me to become an sat tutor.
And so I sort of learned overnight how to,
how to tutor and got into
that whole business. And, um,
it just happened that Brian's
son, uh, needed a tutor.
And so that's how, that's how it
started. And so, you know, I was,
um,
working with his son and a,
and a bunch of his son's friends as I was
starting to write the first school for
good, an evil book. Um,
and so he sort of watched
the entire evolution from
hot shot film maker to broke
and penniless tutor to then, you know,
rising from the ashes into a new career.
So he knows me better than
anyone. My God. Well, he's a,
he is a, he is one of your
biggest fans. I, and, uh,
his enthusiasm,
he's an enthusiastic guy to begin with.
But if we were to spinal
tap that and take it to 11,
the enthusiasm with which you want
it to make the introduction, uh,
was of course an immediate yes.
Then on my part and one thing he mean,
he mentioned to me and uh,
I wanted to dig into this is that,
well first let's back up and
this is going to be a very,
a non chronological interview.
We're going to jump all over the place
cause that's what conversations to do,
but the school for good and evil,
how many books are there
and that series right now?
So there's three books in the series
right now. And then there's, um, a
full color kind of graphic
handbook that's uh, uh,
a companion guide that we offer to like
reluctant readers to kids who hate to
read and will never read novels ever.
But if they want to be
part of the universe,
they get this sort of
graphic version of the world.
So there's either the three novels or
there's the handbook and then I'm in the
process of um,
writing the fourth one as we speak.
And I think they'll probably be in the
end six in the series total. Um, just,
just also because the movies are going
to start to come out from universal.
And so I wanted to have enough books to
stretch out, um, to match the movies.
You didn't want to end up in a,
in a game of Thrones situation
that I there at least once a week I think
of that situation and cannot imagine
that just because,
you know,
I get so involved in my work and like
I take it too seriously at times.
And the idea that you have to share your
secrets of what's going to happen to
somebody who then is going to put it on
TV before you, oh my God, I'd kill myself.
I couldn't do it.
So you are one of the most,
according to Brian, this is our
first conversation. You and I,
one of the most disciplined and
rigorous people he knows in all things.
And one of the adjectives,
adjectives he used was careful
and I wanted to explore
that because I thought it
might lead us to some backstory. So
he said, correct me if I'm wrong,
that you kept tutoring,
you kept doing your tutoring
after you got a three book deal.
Is that true?
I kept tutoring after we made the movie
deal and the movie deal like was enough
for me to not have to work for
like 15 years. So you know,
so why keep tutoring?
Uh,
just couldn't get out of my head.
The idea that art is something
that you should not depend on.
I don't like depending on my art for
income because then I start to think in a
mercenary way. And so, you know, I had
to get through my head that it's okay.
You know, you're, you're
making enough now from,
from the books and the movies that you,
you don't have to us them.
You don't have to confuse money and art.
Because the great thing about tutoring
was it took all the pressure off the book.
Even though I was broke at the time,
even though I had nothing going for me,
it meant that I could write freely because
at the end of the day my money wasn't
going to come from that book, you know?
And so I couldn't let go of tutoring.
I tutored up until last
year. It, it, you know, I,
I went like three or four years longer
than I should have because it just meant
that I had that absolute freedom in
the back of my head that if, you know,
it all went to pot, I still had tutoring,
you know, should have is a tricky word.
Right?
Or it's a tricky contraction because it's,
I like the separation of church and state
that you described in so much as you
not feeling as though you have to
find rent money through your art,
even if your art is compensating
you well psychologically,
PR allowing you to compartmentalize that
you don't think about what will sell
best as the primary directive
of your art perhaps.
Where did you grow up?
I grew up in,
in a little island off Miami
called Keybase gain. Uh,
that is now quite
popular as a resort town.
It has a Ritz Carlton.
It has a Starbucks now.
It had neither of those things
when I was growing up. It was,
it was basically just, you know,
beaches and trees when I grow up.
And it was very, very small. Um, but the
one thing that was famous for was tennis.
Like if you didn't play tennis
on key Biscayne, like, you know,
you weren't part of the cool crowd.
And so that's, it's a lot of, it's a,
it's a lot of where players train
these days. Um, and still, so,
you know,
that's sort of where I grew up.
And how would you describe your,
I don't know what age to pick here.
It's a 10 year old self reward.
Were you a popular kid?
Let me think. No, not until high school.
And I think it was because I
just was a little confused.
I think at that age,
you know,
I was the only Indian kid
on the island I grew up on.
I was one of three people of
color at my high school. Right.
And so you grow up not
looking like anyone else.
And then once I turned 12 and 13 and
I start liking guys instead of girls,
that adds another dimension
to the whole thing. Right.
And so also at the same time,
I'm basically six foot and at
that time I was like 110 pounds.
Wow. Could not but wait on to say
my life. Right. So all those things,
it just felt like I just
didn't fit in any shape,
way or form, you know, and I didn't, I
didn't know what to do. And I think it,
it led me to basically retreat into work.
And so, you know, I became the kid who,
who want everything, right? Like, uh,
they used to give out subject awards at
school. Uh, every year they give out 11,
I'm on the last day of school
and from seventh grade, you know,
through like 11th grade,
I want all 11 every single year.
So it was basically me just
walking back and forth,
picking up trophies because that's
sort of what I did. You know,
I just sort of threw myself into work
and it was only once I got to the later
years of high school,
11th and 12th Grade,
that I think I started to let my
real self come out a little bit.
You know, I just think it,
it broke through on its own.
And I think people started to realize
that I actually did have a sense of humor
for all my workaholic tendencies.
You know?
When did you become openly gay?
I think it was my senior year of college.
Um,
and it wasn't something bad.
It's so funny cause now I watch kids
come out and it's done with such
empowerment and like this
kind of beautiful freedom.
And if there's only one thing I'm sort
of envious of in the entire world,
it's the way that, that kids come
out now. Because when, you know,
we did it in like the
early to mid two thousands,
there just wasn't anything out
there to help you, you know?
And so it was just traumatic
having to come out to people,
to your parents, your friends. Every time
you did it, it was just trauma. You know.
And so I think once I actually came out
is when everything sort of broke open
and that's when,
you know,
like I think the path I was on up until
then I thought I was going to be in
business.
I thought I was going to be a consultant
or a banker or any of these things.
And it was only after I came out that
I think my creative self came back.
It was almost like that had gone
in the closet too. Um, and it,
and it took time for both to come out.
I was talking to a dear friend of mine,
Adam Robinson,
who's been on the podcast
as a guest before,
but alongside several other people
and we just did a solo episode and uh,
he battled with depression for a long
time and I've had my own bouts with
depression.
I'm not saying these are the same thing,
but we had a long discussion about
one of the ingredients being you know,
authenticity meaning not following who
you are or opening up to who you are
fully as one of the ingredients in,
in,
in that particular breed of of depression.
So I've thought a lot about that.
Were you able to be yourself with your
parents at a young age or did they know
you were gay? It was that,
was that a, an open secret?
Could you describe your,
could you describe your,
your sort of dynamic with your
family? You know, my parents are,
are amazing.
Like they're just a both brilliant
people and both at the end of the day.
So open minded.
I don't know if it was so much about
worrying about disappointing them as much
as at that time in the world it was just,
there were no models of, of how
to do it in a, in a real way,
especially in the sort of like
world of Indian families, you know,
there was nothing.
So,
I don't know if it was them specifically
that scared me as much as the idea.
I didn't even know what
it would look like.
I thought if you come out of the closet,
you're going to live this very small,
lonely life. You know? That's what
I thought at the time. And um,
you know what's funny is once I came out,
once I became a writer,
all of these things,
I look back at that time and think,
thank God my life sort of
unfolded the way it did.
Because like if you look at the school
for good and evil books, there's,
there's 120 characters, right?
Each has their own story. It's a,
it's an entire labyrinth world that
I don't keep track of with notes.
Like I just, I know it in my
head, everything's in my head.
And I think all of that energy,
this entire universe of
creativity was trapped, right?
And so no wonder I was a complete
basket case for so much in my young life
because if you can't like,
you know, forget the gaping,
if you're not actually like letting
out this absolute volcano of sort of
creative energy inside of
you, um, it's gonna be rough.
And so I think that's sort of one
of the missions I have in life,
just myself is whenever I sent
another creative soul who's,
who's bottled themselves up,
um,
I gravitate towards them and try
to find a way to let them out.
And that's what the
books are to sort of the,
the message of the books in there
too is for kids is, you know,
find your tribe, right? Like it
don't, don't buy into the Matrix of,
of what the society is telling you.
A successful person or a hero has to be,
find your tribe.
What did you major in Undergrad?
English. Um, just because you know,
when you go to a school like Harvard,
you don't know,
there's nothing practical,
right?
Like a lot of the finance guys will
major in economics or government,
but only out of just sort of default
because there isn't anything applicable at
that at a school like Harvard.
Really. Um, so, you know,
in my head I knew I was going to
go into consulting or banking,
but it didn't matter what Ma,
what you majored in.
So I figured might as well major
in something that I actually like,
which was English. I remember, uh, having,
uh,
an open Q and a not too long ago where
we were talking about where the question
was related to entrepreneurship and I
gave a response and then they interrupted
and they said, well, it's easy for
you to save because you, you a,
you're a male or went to an ivy
league school. And, and I know, no,
but I remember thinking to myself,
the last thing an ivy league school does
is prepare you to be an entrepreneur.
You're so right.
It prepares you,
it molds you to be a very well polished
hog in a fancy machine like consulting
or ibanking. But it does not
in any way probably if, if,
if anything,
uh,
inhibits in many respects
entrepreneurship. But that's,
that could be a whole separate podcast.
I suppose we have to at some point do our,
our dump on Ivs,
I have so much to say.
I almost want to,
to tell like put on my forehead
that like if you went to an ivy,
I probably won't date you, which is
like the ultimate form of self loathing.
Where,
where did,
where did film or the fiction
come into the picture?
You know, I think growing up film
was my love. Like I always wanted to,
um, be in, in film in some capacity.
I thought that's what I
was going to end up doing.
The big problem I thought was that I
was not one of these people craving to
direct just for directing sake. Right? I,
I didn't have this burning desire to,
you know,
be a Spielberg or something like that.
I wanted to control a vision of a world.
Right?
So I already had like a fantasy streak
inside of me. I gravitated towards,
you know, Narnia, Lord of the rings.
Um, all the, all the Grimms fairy tales,
things like that.
And so I think ultimately what I want it
to be able to do only sort of came into
existence once JK Rowling
wrote, um, potter.
Cause once I saw potter I thought,
Oh wait,
this is like exactly sort of the,
the kind of brain I have,
which is create your own universe
control how this universe is going to be
presented in media. Whether it's
it's books, it's film, it's whatever.
And I think that's where school for good
and evil came from at some level was
this um,
you know,
desire to somehow bring a universe in
my head into the world in the most fully
realized way possible.
Combining my interest in both
film and literature. You know,
so I've,
I've,
I have something I can't get out of my
head so I'm going to jump back to tennis.
Yeah. The first thing I was thinking
was at six foot whatever you were,
110 pounds,
you must've had a really mean serve.
That was the first thing I was thinking.
And the second is really a selfish or
self interested question because I have
been considering learning tennis this
year and you've spent an incredible amount
of time tutoring. Granted it doesn't
sound like you were tutoring in tennis,
but how would you recommend I learned to
play tennis for we're going to take it
seriously and what,
what should I focus on and what
should I spend less time on?
Maybe things that novices
waste a lot of time on.
Do you have any thoughts on that?
That's such a good question. It's funny,
I'll tell you, I'll tell you how I
play to this day and it might help,
which is that,
you know,
all year long in New York I play four
or five times a week. Um, you know,
with different people and it's usually,
you know,
we play matches where we hit or whatever.
And then every two months I go down to
Miami to the condo complex I've lived in
since I was a kid and I play with
the coach I've had since I was a kid.
I've been playing with him for 25 years.
And for context for people
listening and uh, you,
you did not lose a first round
match for 10 years. Correct.
What happened was I went 10 years
playing tournaments all the time.
Um,
you know,
after this from high school up until
probably my late twenties and never lost
the first match cause I always
felt like I had paid the entry fee.
I had done so much work to
get there because often the
tournament was in another
state or another country.
I would not lose.
It didn't matter who you put me against.
I had this sort of like killer iron will
that would get me through that match.
And as soon as I started
writing good and evil,
as soon as I was putting all
my creative energy elsewhere,
I think I lost six in a row.
We have to pick and choose where
you put your energy. Right.
So I interrupted you telling me how you,
how you play though.
So I go down to Miami and I play with
the same coach I've been playing with 25
years. He's basically 70
years old. He cannot move.
So what he does is he takes a basket
of balls and feeds me to them.
It feeds me quite slowly and analyzes
my swing on every single one.
So it's 100% about technique
on 100% about timing.
It's as basic as it gets,
but it's like three or four times a year,
he's just training technique.
And if I had a kid or had to,
you know, teach somebody tennis,
it's get your technique perfect.
Because the thing about
tennis is it's so unconscious.
If you try to consciously think your
way through the strokes or anything like
that,
um,
you're gonna end up in trouble just
because of how fast it ultimately goes.
It's like ping pong.
So it has to become automatic.
It has to become conscious of your
technique has to be impeccable.
And so one of the things he taught
me from an early age is, you know,
don't rush to the baseline to start at
the service line and get your technique
right. You know, and then things
will flow. So I became sort of a,
a technique, um, obsessive,
which of course flows into all the other
aspects of my life because I'm big on
technique and process.
Service line is where you serve from.
I know this is your service line is,
is that like the line in the
middle of the air? We go all right.
Now we're at my level things.
What the funny thing about tennis is
it rewards,
it reminds me of like gymnastics and
figure skating where rewards attention to
detail and it a reward sort
of individualistic obsession.
And so it sort of,
you're talking sweet spot
of my personality. It's
just the one sport I love.
And I also think it's a
great sport where you know,
you can put me up against somebody who
is enormously big and powerful and it
won't help them.
You know,
it's a sport where power is not going
to do all that much for you ultimately
against somebody who's, who's fast.
And we can see that, you know, in,
in the men's game now with Djokovich
and Marie and all those guys.
So I have next to me literally
five inches from my left thigh.
I have the book I'm finishing,
which is stories of your life
and others by Ted Chiang.
It's science fiction
compilation of short stories.
And then right next to that is the next
book I was planning on Reading the inner
game of tennis, uh, by Timothy
Gallway, w Timothy Gallway.
I don't know if that's how
you pronounce his last name,
but where do novices waste a lot of time?
We're going to get into
what makes a good coach.
And this is I think going to take
us a few different places, but, uh,
where should I, where should I
not spend a lot of time in the,
and in that relates to how
should I choose a tennis coach?
You know,
I think one of the things is when coaches
put you against other kids very early
and you're playing matches very early
because they want to develop your
competitive instincts. Again, I
think it's super Dunder headed.
Cause what they don't realize is your
competitive instincts are far stronger
than your technique,
right?
So what you'll end up doing is coming
up with this hatchet job way of playing
tennis that somehow we'll do the job to
when you some matches but it isn't going
to serve you well in the long run.
Right?
It's like memorizing openings and chest
versus learning first principles. Yep.
Yes.
And that's how you get to the club and
when you go to the club and you see all
these people with hacking back backhands
or like they sliced both the forehand
and a bat and they they play in a
way that doesn't make any sense.
It's because as a kid they were put
against too many of their compatriots in
competitive matches and we're
never taught actually how to play.
And so I think it's more about finding
a teacher who is technique and obsessive
with technique.
I mean the coach I played with invented
the two and a backhand on tour.
He was the first person to ever use it.
It's a guy named Mike Belkin, you know,
he played Connors at Wimbledon.
So like he all he cares about is are
you hitting the ball in the sort of like
micro meter sweet spot. You know, I can
hit the perfect shot. He doesn't care.
He's, he's just looking at
where I hit it. Like, you know,
and ultimately I think tennis is
about knowing your weaknesses. Um,
and I think my weaknesses,
for instance,
our weaknesses that show up in
other aspects of my life, you know?
So having someone call me out on them a
few times a year actually helps me not
just on the tennis court
but everywhere else.
What are some of your weaknesses
that manifest elsewhere? Oh boy.
I would say um, I mean we can just
trade weaknesses for two hours,
but don't worry all this,
I won't do the same target interview.
He doesn't understand why
my margins are so small.
He thinks that like the comfortable way
to play tennis is to give yourself two
inches of Netclearance.
What does that I see margins.
You mean the space over the net with
wikis are aware it got it. Yeah.
And I mine is like two millimeters
because I just ha I hit the ball very hard
and very flat for the lions and he doesn't
understand why everything has to be
so dangerous,
you know,
which is that same note I get when
I submit my books to my editor.
Why does everything have
to be so provocative?
Why does everything have to be so
aggressively on the edge of what's
appropriate? What I mean so it
shows up, you know, all the time.
I think the other two things are when I
get tense, I tend not to finish my swing,
which I think shows up in life also,
which is when you're nervous or when
you're tense or when you go in with,
you know,
feeling on your heels,
you don't let the full expression
of yourself through, you know?
So that's something that that I
think shows up and maybe also,
and this I think is a common one.
Whenever I'm going through a string of
unforced errors or anything like that in
tennis, it's because I'm hitting the
ball too early. I'm reaching for it.
I'm not waiting for it. Like, it's
not coming into my strike zone,
I'm lurching forward for it instead of,
you know,
holding on a little bit.
Do you do that with, uh,
dealmaking or negotiating things like
that, or where does that, where does it,
where else does that show up? I
think, yeah, I think sometimes it's a,
it's a tendency to want to jump at
something and say yes to everything.
And what I'm lucky to have sort of the,
the greatest agent ever, who weirdly
enough is a lot younger than me,
who basically doesn't let me say yes to
anything. You know, he's just like, wait,
hang on. Like, you know, and it's,
it's sort of, um, start with no,
and then just build from there.
And also just, he's like,
it's not just saying yes,
it's like you have to wait until
something actually excites you, you know?
So yeah. Well is, uh,
another friend of mine,
Derek Sivers, entrepreneur would
say it's either a hell yes or it's,
and no nothing in between. And that's
how he makes his binary decisions.
But you brought up something that I
really want to underscore for people who
haven't experienced it perhaps or who,
who haven't utilized it enough.
And this is a lesson that I revisit quite
a lot and sometimes forget and that is
we we talk a lot about of
uh, or stay in general, uh,
US culture talks a lot about mind
over body and, and uh, so on,
but you can use body over mind
in so much as the sports arena,
the gym, the tennis court
can be used, like you said,
as a way of surfacing and working on
weaknesses that then transferred to other
areas.
And I have found that to be the case,
which is one of the many reasons that
when my exercise regimen is consistently
on point, everything else
improves or as easier. Uh,
so that is, that's something that I'm
focusing a lot on right now. All right,
let's, let's, let's dig into
some of this other stuff,
uh, where to even begin. I've
so many notes in front of me.
I will start with, we talked
about tennis. I want to talk about
Walt Disney and Disney.
So you are apparently obsessed
with Disney Disney world.
Let's talk about it. Why don't you
just, I'll, I'll just let the door,
let the door open and we
can go from there. Well,
I don't know if it was by choice.
I think what happened was we didn't have
TV growing up. We didn't have, um, cable,
Internet, any of these things that would
keep growing it and your parents do.
Growing up that my dad was in
real estate and my mom, you know,
was a very young mom. You know, she had
three kids by 23. So, you know, it was a,
it was a lot going on. So, um, she,
she was trying to figure out how it
all like race three kids, you know.
And back then,
you know,
you had your VCR and your TV that played
a couple channels and that was it. So,
um, we used to complain a lot to
them that we had nothing to watch.
We didn't have an intender,
we didn't have anything.
And so my grandparents finally relented
and came home with the entire Disney
animated collection on Vhs,
which was like,
I think 27 movies or something like that.
Um,
and that is all I watched from what,
from age,
maybe six or seven until 15.
That was all that was in the house.
So like that was our only
source of entertainment.
And so I think Disney at some level
infected every cell of my brain.
And it became for good or for good or bad,
um,
sort of an essential part of how
I thought about the world. Um,
and it was only later on, you
know, once I got to college, uh,
I took a class on sort of a famous
class at Harvard on fairy tales,
taught by a professor named Maria to tar,
who has become sort of like, you know,
the, the most famous expert
on fairy tales in the world.
And she exposed me to the
original grim stories,
which are horrific and dark and insane.
And half the time the evil character
wins and half the time the good character
wins.
And I think that gap between the,
the Disney stories I grew up with and
I took so seriously and the wheel fairy
tales is where the school
for getting evil started.
Because the question that kept sticking
in my head is why did kids 200 years ago
grew up with stories where
the hero didn't always win,
where the hero died a horrible
death if they made a mistake.
And we got these very sanitized versions
of the story where the hero always wins,
even if the hero is not
particularly smart. You know,
you look at the Little Mermaid,
you look at the Lion King Ariel should
die brutally in that movie because she's
an idiot
pleat idiot.
I mean the number of mistakes she makes
in that movie, it doesn't make any sense.
So then to read the Little Mermaid,
the original,
where she dies at the end
suddenly made sense. Right?
And I think that's where I started
thinking, okay, how do we get kids in,
in our world to get the real stories?
How do you get them to start reading
something we're good and evil and balance
where we're actually mean
something. Again, you know,
and I think all of that stuff, and then
the arrival of Potter, um, you know,
my knowledge of Disney,
that all sort of played into what the
skull fucking evil ultimately became,
which is sort of a mix of all of that,
um,
with an attempt to give fairy
tales back to children and,
and sort of make them really
think about what good and evil is.
I remember reading the original
Hansel and Gretel stories,
a few variations,
and there's an illustrated version.
People can check out if they want. They
should read it before their kids read it,
uh, which I think you'll game
and played a part in which,
uh,
really underscores how brutal it's brutal.
Some of these stories were. And, uh,
let's have you said,
I have thought a lot about
Disney in the last few years,
but I've thought about Disney more
so in the capacity of Walt Disney.
And there is a,
uh,
there's a fantastic Walt Disney museum
here in San Francisco for 10 dying to
come out. So good. It's so good. And
it looks at Walt Disney, the thinker,
Walt Disney, the a imagineer, et Cetera,
but also Walt Disney that the
technology innovator. But I,
it's Glenn Beck of all people,
uh,
has a book and he carried it
with him for some period of time.
And my understanding is
that it inspired Disney.
World's the garden cities of tomorrow by,
I've read that book you have by Sir
Ebenezer George Howard. Have you,
have you been to Disney
world? Uh, 40 times,
40 times.
Uh, you know, like I said,
Disney was somebody that I admired so
much that I came to a point where once you
started admiring someone and, and studying
them, you start to see their flaws.
And that's where you start to
see the seeds of your own career.
Because I think once you have an idol
and you studied them long enough and you
realize their weaknesses,
you think, oh wait, I can,
I can come in here with my own voice
and do something totally different.
That's going to ultimately, you
know, be, be its own thing. Um,
and so I studied all that
stuff because I was fascinated.
The most important thing that I was
fascinated about with Disney is his desire
to create his own city. He was obsessed
with this idea of creating his own,
um, not just, you know, Walt
Disney world amusement park.
He wanted his own model community that
the rest of the world would then adopt.
That's what Epcot was supposed to be. Um,
you know, it, it never ended up happening.
And then, you know, for whatever reason
they abandoned it after his death.
But I think, you know, once I'm
done with school for good and evil,
I'm dying to do another series about that.
Sort of analogous to this idea of,
of what the perfect city
of the future looks like.
You bring up something that I'd
like to add two, which is the,
the benefit in a way of heroes
with clay feet. And uh, so there's,
people have probably heard
the recommendation, never
meet your heroes. Uh, and the,
that is said because of the fear and the
reality that oftentimes when you meet
the people you most admire,
they disappoint you in some way.
There is some type of flaw,
there's some type of weakness.
And it's the,
the frame to have,
I think that is more enabling is
the one that you just described.
And that is you shouldn't be,
well actually I shouldn't,
you're allowed to be disappointed.
You can be disappointed,
but even if you feel
disappointed in some way,
everyone is flawed and that should just
encourage you because it humanizes them.
You realize, okay, they're
not some infallible, uh,
you know,
metaphorically some entrepreneurial or
fill in the blank who is hitting every
foul a hundred times
out of 100. It's like, no, they have real
weaknesses and that then, like you said,
opens the door to the possibility that
you could do something of that magnitude.
US. I find it really encouraging
in a way, uh, when I,
when I explore the weaknesses of
people that I really, really admire.
Uh, so, so in any case, I
appreciate you making, uh,
making that point. You know, the
paradox of heroes. Uh, what is,
what does one of your, if you have
one favorite failures because a,
I think a lot of people listening will
think to themselves, good God. All right.
So this guy just seems to be
a savant in everything. Uh,
I can't, I don't have those attributes.
Um, so let's, let's talk about some,
some failure. Uh, you do, do
you have a favorite failure,
meaning a failure that in retrospect,
a really planted the seeds of,
of leader's success? You know,
I think,
um,
one small one and one
big one, uh, which was,
I had sort of tested school for
getting evil at film school, um, in a,
in a three page treatment of the story.
And the professor was this old tra jockey,
you're talking patriarchal culture,
you know,
and trenching kind of guy.
And I submitted it and I went in to
talk to him at office hours and he goes,
so let's talk about this story you wrote
about an Indian family. And I said,
I didn't write the Indian anything.
And he's like, he's like, well,
which one? He didn't have names on
them or he hadn't looked at the names.
He's like, well, which one was yours?
And then like you got distracted and was
talking about how his favorite one was
this one about fairy tales.
And he's like,
whoever the girl that wrote it was like,
she has a future, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
And I said, that one's a mine. And he,
his face just totally changed and he
couldn't get over the idea that I had
written it that like,
you know,
that a boy had written
that story that start,
that had a female lead character was
that in the world of fairy tales.
And he never sort of,
we never went over it because he
couldn't get over the shock of it.
And there was something in that
moment that I think I took badly.
I think I got ashamed of it.
And had I had,
I reacted with a little more
self competence at 23 or 24,
however I old I was,
I would've taken the positive comment
he had given more than the negative one.
Do you? I mean, but for some reason
I felt embarrassed by it. Um,
so that was something that I wish,
but it was an important one because I
think years later when I came back to it
with a little more self esteem, I was
like, out of all the kids in the class,
he liked that one the best. Why
didn't I run with it? That was like a,
it was a serious idea.
The failure that came,
that became sort of the cornerstone in
my life happened after I graduated film
school, which was, I came
out sort of the hot graduate.
I got picked up by ca, um, off a script
that had wine. Don't know, just sorry,
just for context.
A CAA is one of the largest
talent agencies in the world,
if not the largest, but it's
CAA, WME William Morris Endeavor.
Uh, there, there are a handful of
these uta out there with ca is one of,
one of the big mother ships.
And so they had,
they had picked me up and this
scripted won a ton of stuff and,
and it had won this big grant.
And so I immediately got a studio
deal out of England to make the movie.
Um, for, I think it was
a $6 million budget,
which is ridiculous for a graduate or a
movie that you wrote for a movie I wrote.
Um, and so, you know, it
was, it was sort of the,
almost like an autobiographical story
at some level with some fantasy elements
to it. And so I moved to London. I
spent a year and a half prepping it,
doing all the work to get it ready.
You know, we had crews, a setup,
we had a great cast, we had everything
set and it was, um, you know,
right at a bad time in the
industry financially and
the studio and had three or
four flops in a row.
And then there,
their big movie came out
and died and that was it.
They went bankrupt six weeks before
we were starting shooting. Um,
and that was it. That was in a year and a
half. I lost everything I had worked on,
uh,
you know,
worked for all those years and
I just didn't know what to do.
And I remember going home and that's when
I started tutoring and all that stuff.
But the biggest thing that came out of
there is I remember thinking, never again,
that's never going to happen again.
I'm never going to work on something for
two years and putting my life and soul
in it and not have it
see the light of day.
And that's when I realized there has
to be a way to control your Ip, right?
There has to be a way to,
to control the creative property so
that you know you can be in charge.
And that's when I started thinking,
you know,
why don't I go back to what I was
always meant to do, which was fantasy.
And what if I start with it as books
first? You know, what can I do?
But even then I thought,
all right,
say I write a book and it
comes out and no one reads it.
Then we're back at square one. And so
I did a lot of investigation into the,
the kids book industry. And this is
where I found sort of the magic secret,
which is I watched a lot of
authors going on tour, um,
who wrote kids and teen books.
And if you're a teen author,
you tour like an adult author does,
you just go to bookstores every night in
different cities and you meet your fans,
which you know is great. But if you don't
have any fans, then there's no point,
right? If you write for kids eight
to 12, you don't go to bookstores.
Instead,
they send you to schools and you're
putting in front of captive audiences
anywhere from 200 to a thousand
kids at a time who, you know,
don't know anything about you and you
an hour to sell your book three times a
day to three different schools. And
I thought, okay, that I can do that.
I,
if you,
if I write a book good enough and you
put me on tour and I get to see 3000 kids
a day, I can sell. And that's
what got me, got me going.
I realized I could control the
creative and the business side of it.
And for someone who lives their
life wanting control, it was, um,
I saw a career waiting to happen, you
know, so it looks like an accident,
I guess. But I had, I had sort
of seen how it could be done.
So I want to talk about the selling
and now that the more I hear three,
three times a day, a thousand
kids at a time, I'm like,
why have I not been choosing
my genres more intelligently?
Because you can show up to a gigantic
book signing even if you've had successful
books and have 12 people or two people.
I remember going to the UK,
I've never,
so just as a contrast,
I've never done what anyone would
consider a book tour because if after I
remember the four hour work week came out
and I went to the UK and I expected to
have this fantastic launch
and it did pretty well,
but they want it to rely on everything
that happened in the u s and I remember
going to my first book signing that the,
the publisher in the UK was
handling and I showed up and it was,
I don't remember the exact name of the
bookstore show up at seven o'clock or
eight o'clock at night.
It's raining outside and
literally over two hours,
two people showed up.
One person who was just wandering around
and wanted to talk to me about things,
anything that was unrelated to my book.
And then one person who had already
bought the book somewhere else, you know,
nothing, nothing brings you back to
earth like the British. Oh my God.
It was just such a punch in the
nuts. And, uh, after that I was like,
no more much like yourself,
different contexts, but I
was like, never again ever,
ever in my life. Am I going to have
my head's stuffed into the toilet?
This hard from like an ego,
uh, demolishing standpoint. But
I digress. That's my, that is my want.
And I think it's important because
also I think at some point,
you know all the principles that
you believe in and that, you know,
I've been reading your books for years
on and immediately sends to fellow soul.
Um, you know, who is
interested in the same things.
All that stuff kids need.
And the school for good and evil in a
weird sense is kind of a fictionalized
expression of all this stuff.
We're talking about, right.
It's everything, you know,
I believe in about the world and, and
making your own destiny and planning and,
and not fitting in, you know, to,
to society's constructs. And so,
you know,
people who want to raise their kids with
those values I hope would then find,
you know, interest in the
books. But at the same time,
I think your due to write
a kid's version of yours,
cause I just think teenagers more
than anything need it. You know,
and parents will buy it because they
know you. So, you know, I think it's,
it's coming. Well it might, it might.
I've been very intimidated.
Uh,
and then I'm going to come back to the
coming out of college and film school,
a quarter of $1 million in
debt because I think that's,
that's an important topic to dig into.
But I've,
I've been very intimidated by a in,
in a very,
I think good way.
Uh,
some what I would call and
the genre names are confusing.
So young adult fiction,
like 13 plus 13 plus when when
I picked up this was high,
don't know, 2005. Actually
I know exactly when it was.
It was 2005 because it was when I was
doing my walk about around the world prior
to the four hour workweek when
I was doing all my experiments,
I was in Panama and I was reading
his dark materials, Phillip Pullman,
the Golden Compass,
and I had to look up
probably two or three words,
a page to define them for myself.
I mean nautical terms,
all sorts of stuff.
And I remember wondering
who the audience was.
I'll blow your mind on that one.
Golden Compass.
And Philip Pullman is not young adult.
That's middle grade.
That's eight to 12 watts. I it, it's,
I consider myself pretty well
educated guy. Yeah, no, he's in,
he's intense and I think,
but he's part of the whole specter that,
that I aspire to as well,
which is if you look at Narnia,
if you look at Golden Compass,
even if you look at potter, um,
middle grade is where you find the books
that really transcend to adults as well
because is never missing a story is
would that be considered middle? Yeah,
never ending story as well.
I think the problem,
that was my favorite favorite book
growing up in a for three or four years.
And in elementary school it's,
it's an amazing book.
And I think the thing with a lot of
young adult is it's there to gratify,
you know, specific teenage impulses
from 13 to 17 so it's a very,
very sort of melodramatic and
romance based at times, you know,
and I think romance becomes sort of a,
an essential element of it.
Whereas in middle grade you will often
find the more high fantasy, you know,
that you would also find an adult fiction,
which is why I think often some of them,
the best books that crossover things,
like even like if you look at the best,
Neil Gaiman, like the graveyard book,
these are, these are middle
grade books, you know.
So like my favorite audio book of all
time probably is read by Neil himself.
It's, oh good. And so, you know, that's,
that's also why I love this genre because
you know, school for good and evil,
for instance, the number of adult fans
we have is insane. Do you, I mean,
there's no way we would sell as much as
we have sold and been able to do what we
have done without adult readers.
What happens is the kids get obsessed
and then they give it to their parents.
The parents read it, and then they
start getting into it. You know, the,
the trick with the middle grade series
is that the first book has to be a little
younger.
That's why the first Harry Potter book,
they can grow into the rest of the series.
It's, it has to feel like a kid's book.
It has to sort of like
get the kids you know,
into it at some level. Um, and then,
then you can start getting deeper
and deeper and deeper. And that's,
that's sort of how it's done.
Which is why even if you look at his
dark materials, golden compass is,
is a little bit easier, but then two
and three are intense. Top tough. Well,
you mentioned controlling your Ip,
your intellectual property so that you
would be the master of your fate more
than you had been when this,
this,
this film evaporated in front of you,
that you were going to work on
golden compass.
One of my favorite books in that genre
or one of the worst movies I've ever seen
in my life. And I was so fucking
enraged when I came out of that theater.
I was like, how could you, how could you,
I was so upset that they tried to cram
one and a half or two of these gigantic
gorgeous books into 90 minutes or whatever
it was. It just, it just infuriated me.
How,
what have you done or how do you think
about protecting the integrity of your
work? How to, how do you go about
ensuring that is likely to be the case?
Because I'm not going to generalize,
but yes, I am. I'm going to you,
you don't want to take people's word
for it in Hollywood or anywhere else.
That's just, there are too many players
are too many cooks in the kitchen.
So what do you do? Um, well,
first thing I do is I have this piece
of paper and anytime I get on the phone
with anyone from La,
uh,
I put it on my wall and
it says they are lying.
Um, so I have, I've been doing that for
about three years and it really, because
they are lying,
they're saying whatever they need to say.
It's the great thing about,
you know,
Hollywood is once you
figure out that it has,
is that essentially the
same kind of engine as,
as the political system designed
to slow things down, designed to,
to make things move as slowly as possible.
And you start to realize that it's
essentially like working with Congress.
Then for some reason you start to
accept it, you know, a little more. Um,
I think the difference with me
is I come from that world, right?
So like I had gone to film
school, I'd come out, um, and,
and been involved with not just the
movie that you know, had evaporated,
but I was getting offered a
lot of projects at that time.
And so I had met a lot of people.
So when it came to, to, you know,
selling the rights of
school for good an evil,
I got to pick who it was.
I didn't just go with whoever gave,
you know, the, the best offer. So I've put
together the producing team, which was,
um,
you know,
Jane starts who did Ella enchanted and
tuck everlasting and is and is known for
putting together the most
faithful children's adaptations
of all classic books.
I mean, that's her, her reputation and
then put her together with Joe Roth,
who is Alice in Wonderland Maleficent,
you know, Snow White and the Huntsman,
who's the big blockbuster
fairy tale producer.
And sort of that combination has
been kind of the magic bullet, um,
because a,
I got to make sure that I wrote the first
couple of drafts of the script to make
sure that we were in the right
direction before I stepped off to,
to keep working on the box. And then it
made sure that we got on somebody who,
um, a new screen writer, you
know, who would, who would
put in the studio's notes,
who also loved the books at,
which turned out to be,
right now it's David McGee who wrote
finding Neverland life of Pi and is doing
the new Mary Poppins for Disney. And his
daughters loved the book. So, you know,
I've been reading every single draft of
the script. I've been involved, you know,
every step of the way.
And it,
I as of now could not be
more faithful to the books.
That is not to say that it will not end
up being the worst movie of all time.
That has nothing to do with the series.
But you know,
all you can do as an author is,
I would say the,
the advice would be hold on to it until
you put together the right team yourself.
You don't just hand it
over. How do you, uh,
whether it's through
social engineering and just
managing relationships
in a particular way,
how do you minimize the likelihood of
really stupid studio notes getting forced
into your script?
You know,
I think that time has helped because
of social media. You know, the,
the fan base of the series is
getting bigger and bigger by the day.
And I think they have learned from too
many things like golden compass are
beautiful creatures or,
or movies where the fans revolted
before it ever came out. You know,
and you have to have the fans on
board because at the end of the day,
they're the ones who are going to
make all the noise. Right. You know,
like my biggest goal when I
wrote good evil was, you know,
like, look, the way to,
to make a success is not necessarily
the most readers straight off the bat,
but to have the most passionate ones,
you know,
so well they become your marketing for
us. That's it. And that's everything.
And you know,
to this day I spend at least half an
hour a day doing fan engagement to make
sure that, that the people who
love the books most, you know,
get as much access as possible.
Uh,
what have you found most effective
for that in that half hour? Well,
it's tricky because with
eight to 12 our core fan base,
I don't think it's really eight to 12
it's more like 10 to 15 but I think they
are not on social media so much.
Right? They're not on Twitter,
they're not on Instagram.
So we built an interactive website that
is I think the best of any kid series in
the world in terms of how
complex and how much it offers.
There's 18 moderated chat rooms.
There's like games,
there's contests every week
we have a youtube channel,
like there's so much for them to do there
and there's a forum in the in the chat
forums called questions for Soman and
they can ask me questions, you know,
anytime they want and I go on half an
hour a day and answer them all. God,
it got centralized now.
You all right now each,
we'll get a little lay this out. So each
year looking at, looking at some specs,
your player stats, these are really
stats, but you write a 500 to 700 page,
book your tour, 60 to 80 days,
film a weekly Youtube show,
work on film,
manage the business side of the
school for good and evil. Um,
plus parenthetical,
you're single at the moment,
which is a part time job in and of itself.
How New York,
which is not just the part that
it's like death of your soul.
Well you also have in New York
that it's a whole separate,
you have the extra layer of paradox
of choice, plan, shopping issue.
There's a,
there's a,
there's an abundance of riches in some
respects that makes it challenging.
But what is your time
management look like?
What are the keys to your time management?
What do you do differently?
I know there's a lot of questions,
but I'd love for you just to describe
how you keep things in order and
prioritized. Well, I think
the, there few tricks,
the big trick is one day a week is
where anything not essential happens.
So like if I have to meet my
agent or get a haircut or like go,
you know, do some press thing or
a radio interview or something,
all of that happens on one day.
So like everything gets shoved into,
usually it's Tuesday,
Tuesday becomes the like the funnel
day for anything miscellaneous.
Yeah. And so, you know, I think
that becomes the main day.
And then I think for me it's all
about segments, you know, so like the,
the sort of core anchors of my day or I
play tennis in the morning at usually at
seven, um, and I workout
with my trainer at too.
And just having those two anchors makes
everything goes so much smoother because
then I have a big block in the morning
from eight 30 to one to like write and
manage what else,
where else I have to,
and then after I trained from
like three 30 to six. Um,
so I just think that becomes the,
the,
the way I manage time is,
and also if you're, you're
fueled by those two workouts,
do you come back like ready to go,
you know, you're just like in it.
And so I always feel like I'm,
I'm operating like pure
adrenaline at any given time and,
and operating very single
mindedly on something. Um,
and then I tried to finish working by
seven because I also think if you work too
late,
it ruins the work the next day.
Are there any particular tools that
you use to help you manage all of this?
Um, this is, I've had fights
with friends over this.
Who Do you think I should use a calendar,
but my, when we were growing up,
my dad never used a calendar for his
business and he just wasn't into it.
He just felt like he could
keep everything in his head.
And I don't know is how he grew up.
It's how I grew up.
I never kept track of my homework
in school. I never wrote stuff down.
And so I don't have a calendar,
which is so ridiculous to say out loud,
but I don't have a calendar.
Do you know,
is that a reflection of just having
a prodigious memory or is it more,
is it a reflection of it
being more free flowing?
Do you wake up in the morning knowing
exactly what you're going to do in those
two major blocks of time or,
I think that's it.
I think it's because I know the anchors.
I know what's happening. The only thing,
I mean obviously if I have to attend to
scheduling a trip for April or something,
I'll have it written down somewhere.
So let's, let's as an exercise,
so today's Tuesday, today's
your odds and ends day. Yeah.
What does tomorrow look like for you
and what are your key priorities?
If you can talk about them? Yeah. So
tomorrow. Okay. So I'll get up at,
I usually get up about six and
then what do I do in the morning?
So I'll meditate for about 15 minutes.
What type of meditation?
How do you meditate? Oh, that's a, that'll
take us down a whole rabbit hole. Okay.
We'll come back to that and I'll,
I'll,
I'll bookmark that a 15
minutes of meditation and
then I start my day everyday
with,
um,
I boil water and then I put a towel over
my head and I inhale steam because for
some reason it gets a sweat going.
And somehow clears out my head. I don't
know. It just like something I do, which,
which always works and it just feels like
you went to a sauna in your house. Um,
and then I'll eat,
uh,
grab a juice from the place next
door and then gets a tennis by seven.
I'll get home by eight 30.
I'll be writing by nine.
And then right now I'm working
on revisions to the first
10 chapters of book for,
so I'll do that until about
one, then I'll eat. Um,
then I'll go meet my trainer
and we trained from about,
do you have a set lunch that you have?
Yeah,
so we were talking about
this before we came on.
I can't cook and I just don't
have time to think about food.
So I have tried to every meal delivery
service in New York City and um,
I used the portable chef,
which is really good, uh,
which is basically like a customized
personal shaft and they'd deliver all your
meals for the day to day before. Got
It. Um, so everything's set for you.
So that one's really great. Heart and
belly is really good. Um, and it's not,
it's not like blue apron or something like
that where you have to like have pots,
right. As minimal. So you're, you
heat it up and you're ready to go,
ready to go to then, um,
yeah. Then I'll go train with,
with trainer Dave as I call
him from two to about three 30,
and then from four to six 30 or seven
is that second block where right now it
will still be revising. But you know,
inevitably there's business stuff too.
So I tried to do that, um, in a solid
hour, uh, as well. So that's you.
And then, because I work in my, on
my apartment most of the time, um,
after seven I leave, I never
am at home. After seven,
I always go out or a do something, see
friends, you know, or go on a bad date.
What are your, what are your favorite
ways to wind down after a day?
Do you have any people?
And it's just, you know,
the good thing about having lived in
New York for 15 years is, you know,
I've met so many cool
people and so, um, you know,
I tried to to go see a show,
go see a movie.
Inevitably one of my friends, I have a lot
of actor friends were in, in things. So,
you know, there's all, there's
always something. Yeah.
Do you have any prebid rituals or
anything that you do typically before bed?
If I really want to sleep well then I'll
stop watching anything by 10 even nine
30 because I think I'd rather read than
watch TV because for some reason I just
have a very sort of like open,
spongy brain.
And if I watch TV too close to bed,
that's what I'm going to dream about
when I'd rather not be dreaming about,
you know, the real housewives
of New York. What do you,
what are you reading at the moment or
what's the last book that you found
memorable?
You know,
I've read this book three times now
and I keep trying to stop rereading it,
but I think it's maybe the
best book I've ever read. Um,
called a little life by Hanya Yanagihara
that came out the little life,
a little life, a little life.
Um, it's big. I mean it's,
it's almost 700 pages.
Um,
but I think it was nominated for the
Pulitzer or something and it's just
incredible. It's, it's about, you know,
these four male friends who grow up in
New York City together and it's sort of
tracking their life from when
they're 20 to 60 and you know,
for p for anybody who,
who loves to have a bigger view of what
life is and look beyond sort of the,
again, the Matrix of what life is supposed
to look like according to society,
that book will just completely
sort of ravage your brain.
And so I just think it's,
I give it to so many people and never
once has anyone come back to me and not
said like, that changed my life. You know?
I think that might be the title of a,
of this podcast, episode ravage, Ravenous,
ravaging your brain for
how much was so much. Uh,
so a few things.
The first is meditation.
What type of meditation? So,
or describe your meditation.
It, it's super simple. It's just
going to sound a little crazy. Um,
terribly long. Cause I've been
doing this for a long time. Like I,
I remember I read the Tao Te Ching when
I was 23 or 24 and going through a rough
time after the movie had collapsed
or maybe it was a little later,
a copy of it also six inches
from my left thigh. Okay.
And I remember reading it being like,
okay, this makes no sense, you know,
but you just keep reading
it again and again.
And slowly I started to get the point of
it, which was thank God I played tennis,
but it was saying the same thing that
I talked to you about tennis earlier,
which is there should not be any
decisions. It should be automatic.
It's not automatic because
there is something in the way.
And the thing in your way is the I
the ego, your self consciousness.
So every meditation I've done since then,
and it's not been 10 years,
it's 15 minutes of trying to find the eye.
That sort of energy that makes
up that conscious will, you know,
inside of me and realizing that that's
actually the place that you do not want
to operate from that that is
actually an illusion, right?
That's just residual anger and frustration
and your inability to control things
in the world. Right? So
all of my meditation is,
is recognizing the eye that you operate
from and the world tells you to operate
from. And realizing that that's
what you have to let go of.
So when you sit down, assuming
you're sitting, are you,
then I'd like you to get as
concrete as you can describe it.
Are you imagining the me,
so to speak, in parentheses,
behind the sitting behind the eyes and
trying to visually or graphically observe
it?
Are you,
are you observing the words in your
head as a detached third party?
What are you doing exactly? It's more
like trying to sense the me, right?
Just sort of thinking,
okay, where is I, where,
where is I in my body right now?
Right?
And trying to actually imagine
like your entire perception,
your entire consciousness,
everything that's in your mind,
everything that's in your body,
everything that's in your
thoughts right now is that I,
and realizing that all of it is
actually wrong, right? All of it is,
is energy that you're holding
that needs to be let go of. Um,
and what you really want is empty space.
I think that the line and the top
stitching that stuck with me the most is,
you know, why is there something
when there should be nothing. Right?
And it's that whole idea of,
of the true happy human is clear.
There shouldn't be anything there. Um,
and so that's what the meditation is.
It's trying to find the bi,
the,
that center of like me. Like, you know,
I can I actually identify what the
me is and then realizing that that's,
that needs to be let go. So
you're, you're very self directed,
even lacking.
So
you are, I hope you have, I hope that
the studio has good key man. Insurance.
Would be, uh, it's, it's a
great point of leverage though,
having this entire world you've
created inside your own head. Uh,
not without its risks,
but
you mentioned having a trainer now,
uh,
in doing some of my review before this,
you appear to train exclusively with
trainers. I am almost the opposite. Uh,
said lift to your why that is. Wait
first, tell me why you're the opposite.
I am, uh, no, it's, it's,
it's not entirely, uh,
it's changed a bit in the
last few years when I've, uh,
I've realized that there are certain
types of physical movement that I view as
recreation, physical recreation,
not primarily training.
So I'm not doing them to lose body fat
or fill in the blank like acro Yoga,
acrobatic yoga partner,
gymnastics, that type of thing. Uh,
and there are certain instances where
you need a technical coach tennis,
a gymnastic strength training. In those
instances I will have a coach, uh,
whether I'm using video or otherwise.
But training for me,
exercise has always been my me time,
my meditative time to live in the present
moment and very often use some type of
cadence as um, as a, I never
thought of it this way,
doing this up until maybe a few years ago,
but a mantra of sorts
where I'm simply counting,
say the second sub seconds down from
particular lift or the number of
repetitions.
And that for me is my,
my mental palate cleanser for
the day. It's, it's, uh, for,
for a very long time was my
version and a sense of meditation.
So I didn't want to
banter with someone else.
I didn't want to have any type of
sensory input from someone else.
And so that's why, that's why I
trained by myself. Uh, that's,
that's still the case with
a say a weightlifting, uh,
in less.
It is a very technical skill and I'm
working with someone for say an Olympic
weightlifting movement where the penalty
of doing it incorrectly, so high end,
you really require a set,
a separate set of eyes to correct
because what you think you're doing is
probably not what you're doing at
least in the beginning. So that's,
that's why I've,
I've always trained alone end.
I like to train late so I love
to train at nine 10:11 PM for a,
for a host of reasons. But
uh, I have a theory though.
I think that you might instinctively
be what I call a somatic person,
which is like you,
when it comes to anything in the body,
you want to push yourself,
right?
So you won't let yourself get
away with incorrect form or,
or not pushing yourself to the Max. Yeah,
let's do that word that that's true.
That is true.
Which is not the,
which is like mentally when I'm working
on a book or something, I will die to
make sure it's perfect. Right. To make
sure that it's, it's exactly right.
But when I get to a workout,
my instinctive thing just cause I grew up,
then I grew up like,
you know,
the kid who never thought he
was ever going to be strong,
who kids always made fun of for
being skinny. So when it came to,
to lifting weights and things like
that, I came in scared. Right.
And I always bailed before it ever
got heavy thinking. Like, you know,
I'm too weak to do this or whatever
I needed. I need trainers to push me.
You,
I mean at some level like I need them to
say this is what you're doing and we're
not getting out of it, you know? Right.
And I think, cause if it was just me,
I don't know, I would, I don't think it
would be the same. And I also think like,
it, it let's me not have one, it
lets me have one moment of the day,
what I'm not in charge, which is nice.
Right, right, right, right, right.
This makes a lot of
sense. Yeah. This good.
This could lead into all sorts
of relationship discussions
are interesting thing.
But, um, the, uh,
how many trainers have you worked with
or is it always the same person or a
handful of people? So I work with
the same trainer in, in New York,
treader Dave trainer,
Dave,
his name is Dave Stock Zyl at
Crossfit Nyc and I chose him,
the same ones you got to get a lot busier.
He is an absolute genius and I chose
him the same way I chose my agent,
which you're going to laugh at, but
I chose them both by their photo. Um,
and I think it's because I spent so much
time casting movies that I'm very good
at at just when I see a photo or maybe
I spent too much time on Tinder or
something.
But like I,
I know when I see a photo
that like that's the person.
And so I remember going through all
the crossfit gyms in New York and like
looking at photos and
I saw his and was like,
that's the right guy and
I have to pause here.
So what can you, is this purely
subconscious or is there some,
is is what you do a teachable skill?
Do you think? No, I think it's,
I think it's instinct. It's, it's,
it's a, I'm looking for with trainers.
I was looking for like a, a softness
kind of like a kind eyes type of thing.
Yeah.
Like a non bro Bro.
Right, right. Yes I do.
And, and that's him. He's,
he's the guy you go to if, um, you know,
you aren't like if you,
if you're coming at weight training, not
from like the bro his place, you know,
what do you do when you're on the road?
Then I get a trainer every single city,
every single day I'm in. It's a,
it's a bit obsessive. But how do you,
how do you find them and how do you choose
or are they all photograph based? No,
no, no. That's too much work. So that
the assistant, does she, she knows,
um, you know, I don't know. She just,
she's pretty good at knowing
what to look for now because, um,
I've been on enough tours that
I'll be like, that one was great.
That one wasn't that great. So she,
she started to get a sense of like,
you know what I'm looking for, but
I've worked with, you know, so many,
so many different trainings. Uh, trainers.
I think what makes Dave so great is he
figured out very early on that it wasn't
just going to be crossfit that I needed,
but he's mixed in a ton of GSD stuff,
which is the gymnastic strength
training. Um, a lot of z health stuff,
which is like exercises that also
compliment like brain neurology.
Like he's very good at customizing
based on your personality, what,
what your goal is.
Like,
he knows not to give me intense
conditioning pieces cause I can out cardio
anyone on the planet, you know, I
mean it's just the way I was born.
So he's focusing on, on
my weaknesses, you know.
Got It.
All right,
well I'm not going to spend too much
time on trainers cause there's so many
other places I want to dig quarters,
million dollars in debt.
That's a fuck ton of money, uh,
after Undergrad and, uh, the MFA.
So how did you and your family make
the decision to go so far into debt?
Because in the u s there's a very,
and I think this is dangerous
on a lot of levels and anti,
at least in Silicon Valley, there's a very
romanticized anti college notion. Yeah.
And I do think that student debt can be a,
a paralyzing problem for many people.
How did you decide to go?
How did you and your family
decided to go that far into debt?
And I don't know if it was
you or you and your family.
I don't know how that was arranged.
I think, you know, at some level
Indian families are,
are a lot like Jewish families and,
and other sort of,
you know,
cultures that put a primacy on education
where there is this expectation that
your family, we'll pay for school. Um,
and my dad was going through
a hard time in, in the 80s,
um, you know, cause he was in
real estate and that's when,
when the market was tanking and you know,
he took on a lot of debt himself
in order to, to pay for Harvard.
So I don't think Harvard is where
the main source of debt came from.
Main source of debt came from
film school and you know,
there was no way he was going to pay
for that or I was going to let him. Um,
and so it was just yes,
my decision really to basically be like,
okay,
I was so diluted I guess into thinking
that like somehow I was going to pay it
back. Um, and I look at some of the
kids who came out of film school and,
and are saddled with so much that now and
I just don't know what you do. Like I,
I was lucky enough to discover tutoring,
which paid really,
really well and I was lucky to get a
ton of clients and do really well at it.
So that's what got me through
and ultimately the book
deal help me. So, you know,
sort of pay the rest off,
but mmm. It is gamble.
That is not wise I think.
Okay. All right. So, so now,
now we're getting to the next
question, which is advice. So
much like college has a sort of
lost its luster for a lot of people.
Although I,
I do generally think that if you can
get into a top tier name recognizable
brand, which sounds terrible, but
whether it's Undergrad or say Mba,
then it can be worth it.
Sometimes. I agree with you.
The film, the MFA Film School, uh,
is also one of those um,
divisive topics where a lot of successful
filmmakers will say waste of time.
But then there are many successful
filmmakers who come out of film school,
aspiring filmmaker,
uh,
about to graduate from Undergrad or
has already graduated from Undergrad,
did decently well in however
we want to think about that.
Should I go to film school?
They love film.
Maybe they've done a few short films
in some elective classes in college,
but their major or something else.
Should I go to film school?
What do you say to that person or what
do you ask them? What's the conversation?
What would I say now? I would have such
specific advice now, which is only gay,
go to film school. If you can get
into USC, that would be my only,
my only advice.
And the reason why is the industry has
changed so much to basically eliminate
independent film so that the only sort
of productive education you're going to
get in film school that will
lead you to, you know, uh,
Hollywood career at some level is to be
in southern California at USC. You know,
maybe Ucla where you have studio
connections and are working with studio
professors. And if you're good enough
you're going to get, um, you know,
you might get seen. That's what I would
say. Cause when I went to Columbia,
it was in the heyday of the,
of independent film at some level.
And so a lot of the great things that
happened to me at Columbia where,
because I had access to all
these successful, you know,
independent directors and producers who
love my work and therefore introduced me
to all these great people who all those
people now are having trouble making
films of course, because there's
no outlet for them, you know,
so they've all gone to television
or whatever. So film at some level,
if you want to work in film, we're
talking working, you know, in,
in the studio world,
which means you gotta be in La,
you have to get to be at one of those
two schools. But otherwise I would say,
I don't think there's a need for it.
I don't think,
I don't think you need to
go to film school. I think
you just need to make work.
Yup.
This is the USC reference or,
or I guess a recommendation with caveats.
Uh,
makes me think of Stanford also in
my backyard here in the bay area and
certainly as a compute, as a
competent computer science major, the,
the demand for engineers
so outstrips supply. It's,
it's just ludicrous.
But if you want to be part of the Silicon
Valley tech scene and you're debating
between different undergrad options than
silicon valley and being based in Palo
Alto where you have all of the venture
capitalists literally in the same town or
right next door, uh, gives you a, can
give you a huge leg up. Similarly,
depending on which facet of the
business you want to be a part of.
It was the one school
that I didn't let my uh,
well cause I helped so many kids with
their college applications over the years.
Stanford was the one school I rarely,
rarely kind of let them apply to.
Why is that? As I, I said
it was too hard. I said art,
I said the problem with
Stanford is that you have to,
the college application game
is very simple. Whichever
school you apply to early,
you better be fairly sure you have a
good shot at getting in because you know
when you apply early, um, your
chances of getting in are much better.
But you have to at least
be in the game to get in.
Stanford's acceptance rate is so low
and everybody applying to Stanford is so
good and so smart that to get
in it takes an act of God.
You better be like, you
know, a real miracle nature.
And so it was the one school I
recommended more often than not,
I just said you are throwing away your
application because they don't take
anyone. It's harder than Harvard is
Harvard then, then Yale, it's harbor.
Then any school. Stanford is, to me,
Stanford's is a top school in the
country right now. It's a great school.
It's a great school. If their, uh,
their business school programs is also
outstanding. I considered it. I had this,
I, I always thought I should have gone
to Stanford had I been able to get in.
I mean I applied early to Princeton,
got accepted,
ended up having a very difficult time
at Princeton. Always thought, you know,
I would have been much better off having
gone to a brown or a Stanford. Yeah.
Cause you're, you're not at Princeton
is very square. Yeah. And I ended up,
uh, I don't know if I've ever talked
about this publicly. I ended up,
I don't know if you're familiar with
the very weird eating club. Absolutely.
Social structure at Princeton,
but in effect for people who aren't
familiar with this, you have the,
you have a street.
If you have a street that is lined with
gigantic mansions and that is where the
partying happens generally welcome to
Princeton, Princeton, gigantic mansions.
They're all stylistically different, which
is very odd, so you have kind of old,
tiny blue blood,
New England rich mansion.
Then you'll have colonial style going to
Georgia bell from old money mansion and
then it goes on and on.
It's a very odd place and they're
effectively coed fraternities.
It's easiest way to describe it where
you also eat meals and some of these
eating clubs, it's just
mindblowing. Like Ivy for instance,
I believe has an endowment so to speak,
that is larger than some name brand
universities in the United States.
It's just mind blowing end.
I ended up trying to fit in in some
of these eating clubs and getting very
disillusioned and unhappy and then
joining an eating club called terrorists.
So terrorists,
to give you an idea,
had a rainbow flag flying out
front. I am. I would have loved it.
I am not gay, but it's where all the,
it's basically like your Tuesday.
It's where the,
it's where the odds and ends,
the people who didn't fit in
anywhere else ended up going.
And it was the one thing,
I don't give any money to Princeton for
reasons that you guys can look up if
you're, if you want to read, uh,
some practical thoughts on suicide
and essay that I wrote, then a,
that'll give you an idea why
don't give money to Princeton,
but I do give money to terrorists
because it's saved me. Um, anyway,
I'm not sure how we, how I got onto
that, but I didn't, I didn't fit in,
in any way at Princeton whatsoever
because I think most of your listeners at
some level, regardless of, you know,
whether on the outside they fit in or not,
I think inside they don't, which is why
they're looking for something different.
And that's also why I wrote the
books. Right? I felt like, you know,
when I was growing up, there were no
books for the odds and ends right there.
The hero always won.
It was always the good looking guy.
Like even if you read Harry Potter,
like he's always the good kid.
He always does the right thing,
you know,
he's going to win at the end because
there's no version of potter where Harry
ends up in a pool of blood and
Voldemort goes kicking into the sunset.
And I've wanted to write
a book that questioned all
those assumptions, you know,
in some level and said,
okay, what about us?
What about us Weirdos who root for the
villains or are US Weirdos who don't
think evil is what evil is made out to
be and that good often is not good and
you know, all those sort of sort
of big questions. So, um, yeah,
it's why I think I've always
been attracted to your work and,
and people like you at
some levels because um,
that sort of questioning reality of what
the structure is is so important and I
think kids are helpless to do that.
And,
and if we can train them
not to through books,
cause that's our number one medium to
sort of get to them. Um, I think it's,
it's a big deal, which is why I sort of
take what I do. Like I said too seriously,
probably. I mean, I think that anyone
who's really good at what they do really,
really good,
tends to have a
certain degree of pathological
obsession with, with what they do.
If you had to recommend
books on writing or books that
would help someone's writing,
um, is there, is there a shortlist?
Are there any of that come to mind?
Let me think. I think, and I'm
not gonna, I'm not gonna make it.
John was specific on purpose. It could
be, it could be anything. For instance,
I'm a nonfiction writer at this point,
but bird by bird,
which is written and Lamar
for fiction writers really,
I found just the best, the cheapest
therapy that money could buy. Yup. Yup.
Yup. That's, that one's an
amazing book. I think, you know,
I'm less interested in books specifically
about writing because I think writing
to me is like breathing you right,
the way you breathe.
Everybody has their own way of
doing it. Everyone, you know,
every true writer has to write to
stay alive because that's how we,
that's how we live, you know,
that's, that's our connection
to the sort of cosmos.
And so every writer has their,
their specific process.
I don't get so much out of a
writer books what I do get books,
you know, out of our two things, one
books about creativity and then, you know,
sort of like creative spirit and then
documentaries about creative process.
Those are the two things
I sort of look at.
And so one of my favorite
books is called the spark. Um,
it was written by Cirque du Solei about,
very cool. I love Cirque de Solei. Um,
and they have a book called the spark
about where their ideas come from.
It's very short, you can read
it in like 20 minutes. Um,
but it's fantastic and it gets to this
idea that so much of creativity is about
the fact that we try to
control it. Right? That again,
it goes back to that idea of the eye
that I'm trying to get rid of that if we
just let go of this idea of,
of the conscious I trying to control
when we work creativity and create to
creatively,
that's when the universe comes rushing
through and it's so it's about almost
making yourself into a clear vessel and
accepting that that you know it's going
to come.
And I think one of the great things about
writing a series is that now that I'm
on book four and I've settled into
a rhythm, I start to trust myself.
And when I trust myself is when the
great stuff happens because I'm not
monitoring, I'm not judging.
And when you're not editing,
when you're generating editing
and you're getting twit,
I'm getting twist after twist where every
chapter is ending in a twist that like
I never predicted the characters doing
something I'd never had any idea they
would do. And it's happening versus
you know, the first couple of books,
first three books where it's, you know,
every chapter, one twist or whatever.
Now it's constantly,
constantly, constantly,
because I'm allowing myself to take
things in new directions. And uh,
along with the spark, um, they've
got a cool documentary called,
I think it's called the fire
within, that follows, um,
eight people that try out for
Cirque du Solei. And it's sort of a,
it's kind of a wonderful Canadian
documentary about, um, just, you know,
people passionate about their heart.
Um,
and then the other thing is I'm obsessed
with a documentary is about creative
process,
specifically about fashion designers.
Because if you look at fashion,
it's where you get 100% under diluted,
uh,
creativity because it's on such a short
cycle with all the different fashion
shows. And so it's also in a sense, I
mean purely subjective, which makes it,
which adds to the creativity by
necessity in some respects. Yes.
And so you get to sort of watch these
madcap geniuses who aren't constrained,
right?
Because again,
it's subjective so they can do whatever
they want because people have already
judged them to be geniuses at some level.
So you, you get these amazing things.
So you know,
things like Dior and I or Valentino,
the last emperor or Lagerfeld
confidential. Um, if you,
if you had to pick one of those
three for a non fashion, I'm,
I'm the most disheveled unfashionable
person you could possibly imagine.
Which of those three should I start with?
Let me give you another one then.
I think,
let me give you one that I think the
best of them all is called ballet for 22
and it's on Netflix.
It's a,
so American Ballet Theater has
a choreographic internship.
That's I think the most procedures
quo choreographic award.
A young person can win and people compete
I think from all over the world for it,
I think.
And one the person who won it one year
was someone inside their own company who
was just sort of a middling dancer in
their company and who's only 24 which I
think the youngest I've ever given it to.
And it tracks his internship
and his choreographic process.
And when you meet him you'd think
he's a complete Yahoo. Right?
You just think this, he doesn't seem
smart. He doesn't seem charismatic.
The guy's name is Justin Peck.
You don't see why they gave it to them.
You're just sort of watching this
movie thinking it's dull, you know,
watching paint dry because
there's no narration.
It's 100% watching this guy work
and about 15 or 20 minutes into it,
you start to see him at Orrick and you
start to realize slowly by slowly you are
watching a genius and you're
watching like a Mozart who was,
who was just gifted with something
that is absolutely unrivaled.
And it's only like an hour and 10 minutes,
but it's the best hour and
10 minutes you'll ever spend.
Cause you'll get to see true genius in
process without any editorializing. Oh,
cool.
And He's 22 ballet for 22 and he's since
become the best choreographer in the
world. Wow. And he's, he's
young, you know, but you,
you get to watch it happen.
Have you seen, and it's, it's a bit of a,
they use this in a loving way,
bumbling documentary. It's,
it doesn't take itself too seriously.
Uh,
but there are aspects of it that I've
found so hilarious that I could, I could,
I could, uh, I could charge through
it, but six days to air about,
tell me about it.
It's about the South Park team putting
together an episode from scratch,
zero nothing to shipping finished
product for air in six days.
I would see that. I love after they
went to the, I wanna say the, Ah,
I'm so out out of La la land.
Maybe went to the Emmy's,
perhaps I'll just say the Emmys,
they went to the Emmy's,
the Golden Globes or something in
women's dresses on acid and the only,
the committed to each other that every
time they're interviewed on the red
carpet, they could talk about
anything except for the dresses.
They couldn't even make a mention of
the fact that they were in dresses and
they're on acid. And then they get back
to the office and they're like, holy fuck,
we only have six days to ship a new
episode. Better get to work on that.
And then it's just crunch time all
nighters in Saturday that's being watched
tonight.
Sounds so good with that and like that
kind of stuff where you get to see how
the sausage is made. Is is really the
only type of documentary I want to watch.
There's,
there's another one that everybody should
watch called dumb theater of war about
the making of mother courage.
Uh,
when they did it in central park with
Meryl Streep and it's the only time Meryl
Streep is ever let anybody
film her rehearsing ever.
And she said she didn't want to
do it cause she goes to rehearsal,
looks like bad acting and she goes,
I don't want to see me, you know,
do bad acting.
And then she goes,
I thought then she changed her mind
and thought maybe it would be valuable.
And to get to watch Meryl
Streep's rehearsal process,
you realize how much it is,
how much a bad, you know, how
much of writing in the beginning,
how much of acting in the beginning.
All of it is bad.
It's just about doing all the bad stuff
to get to the good stuff, you know?
For sure. So yeah, I love it. That's
another great one. All right. I've been a,
I've been making a list of docs to watch.
So now I was already on
this yesterday in my mind.
So now we have a bunch of
new ones to work on. Let me,
let me jump to I suppose what I always
call these rapid fire questions,
but your answers don't
need to be short or rapid.
What book or books have you given the
most as gifts to other people if you have,
besides your own? Um, I would
say a little life for sure.
And then a book called the
velvet rage. Um, the velvet rage,
the velvet rage, which is
extensively about, you know, if,
if you grow up a game man,
like how to deal with it, um,
you know,
in the world.
But I think it's more about
modern masculinity and
about sort of what it means
to be a man in America. And, um,
so even for a Hetero normative?
I think so. I think so. I think,
you know,
the,
the one thing a little life in that
book share in common is an attempt to
deconstruct what,
you know,
the tenants of being a man are in,
in this country because I think it
ultimately restricts emotional health,
you know? And so, um, you know,
I think both those books sort of give
you a window into all alternative and,
and yeah,
here's a,
if you wanted a different shade of gray
in a book with all your spare time that
you, that you might enjoy that a
number of my friends, male and female,
have just found an extremely powerful
is tribe by Sebastian younger.
And I think it's,
uh,
I found it to be just a fantastic,
fantastic and thought provoking book that
helps to explain a lot of what we see
in the world.
And it might add just a different lens
through which to look at that as well.
What is the, what is the best
investment you've ever made?
And that could be energy, time,
money, or any other resource.
And I'll, I'll give you an
example. So, for instance,
Amelia Boone is a three time
world's toughest mudder champion.
Also power attorney had apple,
uh, just a killer Cyborg.
And I asked her this question and she
said it was the entrance fee for her first
world's toughest mudder, or it might've
been our first very toughest mudder.
In either case,
the fee was $450,
which for her at the time was
actually a stretch. But if she hadn't,
if she hadn't done that this entire other
career and life for her wouldn't have
opened. Uh, does anything come to mind
for you? It doesn't have to be the best,
but it could be one of the best
investments. This is so small,
but it made a big difference in
my life, which was that, you know,
um,
I had struggled with just like acne for
a lot of my teenage years and it was
something that like I couldn't get rid of.
And as an adult,
just having like breakouts and
stuff and I, you know, you just,
it starts again in your head a little
bit, you know, that you can get rid of it.
And so you try everything. That's
the problem. When, when you're built,
like you know me and a
lot of your listeners,
you try every effing thing and so
you're going to doctor after doctor,
you're trying antibiotics, you're trying
creams, you're trying every kind of soap.
And I just had had it like I just gave up.
And so then I read this story in the
Times about a company that had started,
it was called AOL, AOL
plus biome. I know. I,
okay. Yes, absolutely. So I
became one of the early adopters.
I was one of the first 10
people to try the product.
Could you describe for people this,
this was my,
my year without soap or something like
that. Oh yeah. So you've done it. Oh, I,
I actually got a prototype sample
of Aot biome way back in the day.
Uh, which, which has its own story too.
But can you describe for people, well,
I mean you could take stab at,
I can take a stab at it,
but could you describe for people what
this is? It's not antibacterial for sure.
No, it's the opposite. Tell me if
I'm wrong. It, as far as I know,
it's a probiotic spray.
It's a spray that's just
pure water and, uh, you know,
bacteria that's supposed to naturally
reside in your skin because they're,
they're sort of hypothesis was
animals don't use soap and, you know,
don't, we'll be, have skin issues
as regularly as humans do. Um,
because they have a certain kind of
bacteria that, that sort of, uh, you know,
sort of oxidizes all the,
um, the bad bacteria.
And so they created this
bacterial spray that they said,
all you need to do is throw
out all yourself, any cream,
anything you've ever used in your
entire life, and just use this,
you don't even have to shower and
you potentially would be fine.
And so I was desperate.
I was desperate.
And so I became one of their first
customers, tried it within three days.
My skin was clear and I had been
using it three and a half years. Um,
they are now called mother dirt. They've
changed their name. Oh, they did? Okay.
Multi plus bio was not, yeah,
it doesn't roll off the tongue.
Marketable. They, they, you
know, and they have, um,
they have a shaving cream now that
you can use. They have a shampoo,
a that you can use that that is
sort of bacteria friendly and man,
it made a difference. Let
me tell you that, like,
it just changed everything because
you just forget the skin thing.
I mean that's just superficial.
But to realize that the problems you were
chasing for 10 years or more than that
could be solved by your own body and buy
something that was natural already that
theoretically like you don't even
need the missed at some level.
Like if I don't have it for a week,
I just don't use soap and then my skin
goes back to who stays completely fine,
you know? Definitely. So it was a,
that was a big shift and it's called
mother dirt now mother dirt mother.
If people want to read
the New York Times piece,
The New York Times does what I do,
which is confusing.
Sometimes they'll use a different headline
online versus in the print edition.
And then it makes things very confusing
for people. But it's the, uh, let's see,
my no soap, no shampoo, bacteria
rich hygiene experiment.
And I think the,
I think the author's name is Julius Scott
discovers what she smells like after
28 surplus days. It's
fascinating. It's really, really
fascinating. Yeah. Everyone,
everyone should be on this product.
I feel like it's a market
that's going to explode soon.
What, uh, what other tricks
do you have like that?
Do you have any other,
uh,
any other expedient solutions to come?
Problems like that and some
of the things, so, you know,
just cause I feel like everyone's
stress goes somewhere in their body.
Like some people get back pain and that
becomes their, their big thing. You know,
with me it's usually it was always
skin until that was solved. Um,
and then I guess when I was younger
it was, um, uh, stomach. Yeah.
One of my best friends has that he has
his, he always gets stomach issues,
stomach issues.
And also because I was on antibiotics
for the skin problems when I was a
teenager. So that was something
that stuck around. And I'm, again,
I did a lot of research and
realized that, um, you know,
you can take a daily probiotic,
but that probably won't be enough.
And so I sort of cobbled together my own
probiotic therapy where I would buy two
or three bottles of different brands and
take those on tour when you're sleeping
at, you know, basically not
sleeping, God knows what you know,
and completely off rhythm
and just by taking, yeah.
Maybe like eight probiotic pills
a night from, you know, whatever,
a combination of different brands.
It's solved all my problems.
I can travel anywhere in the world and
as long as I'm overdosing on probiotics
with different, mixing up different
brands, no issues whatsoever. It's,
it's the mix of the different brands
that I think is, is what is key. Right.
And then the other, the other
thing that helps to sleep, uh,
just in terms of insomnia as if
you have a aroma therapy diffuser,
one of those sort of would diffusers they
can get off Amazon for like $20. MMM.
And Use lavender oil. Yeah. [inaudible]
it old zonk you out very, very fast.
Lavender oil. All right, I'll
have to play around with this.
I started using heat diffuser for the
first time after I had Nicholas McCarthy
on the podcast too is a one armed
or I should say more accurately,
one handed concert pianist and he,
and he uses Geranium
oil when he's composing.
He said it's the perfect mixture
of relaxation without sleepiness.
It's relaxation plus alertness for him.
So I used Geranium oil for,
for a lot of my editing and writing
sessions when I did tools of titans.
Do you use,
do you use the diffuser for anything
other than lavender oil or is that,
do I use, what's funny is
this is such a stupid answer,
but at the sort of food market I go to,
they have this basket of 50% off oils
of whatever as in sold that week or
whatever.
So I just buy whatever's in there.
So I never really keep track of
what's in the diffuser on any day.
It's just a different smell.
Welcome to my life,
but I'm willing to cede control
over what oil is in the,
when, when you're traveling as
much as it sounds like you do 60,
80 days a year and I'm sure you
have other non tour related travel.
Do you have any tips for uh,
minimizing onset of cold, flu, et
Cetera, things like that? You know,
I think
before this, the steam thing
before I leave helps a lot, um,
because it really does clear your sinuses
cause that's where you can get sinus
infections. And I think I was prone
to those, you know, a lot. Um,
and I think when I'm on tour,
and it's funny,
I read a book about Steven Spielberg who
apparently does the same thing when we,
whenever he is, Oh, I'm
sorry. Okay, go ahead. What?
He's shooting a movie for him not
to get sick, which is he drinks,
uh, t incessantly and
herbal tea. Just, you know,
he's just constantly trying to stay warm
because you never know what the weather
is. You never know what the
situation is going to be.
But he's just always downing
hot tea of some herbal variety.
And I think when I'm on tour, everywhere
I go, every time I get in the car,
I get a hot tea. Every time I
get to a school I drink a hot.
So I'm drinking like
seven or eight cups a day.
Do you have a Goto hot tier or is it like
the 50% off? It's, it's, you know, if I,
if I can get to a Starbucks, they've got
the Mint Majesty, which is really good.
I mean,
we should preface this all by saying
that I can't drink caffeine because it
makes me crazy.
Do you drink,
do you drink alcohol or no,
no.
I mean a glass of wine if it's been
a particularly horrific day. But,
um, otherwise, uh, not really. I just, uh,
you don't need it. You don't need
the enhancement or I'll tell you why.
Andy Capp one way or the
other. This is what I would
say, and this is, this is sad,
but I think there's a happy lining to it,
which is that I spent so
long in my twenties and teens
trying to get control of
my brain and trying to, to make it a happy
place. Do you know what I mean? Sure.
And when I finally found peace of mind
and sort of the creative space to be able
to work in and now live
in a, in a fairly, um,
I dunno, just like constant
state of, of goodness.
I don't want to mess it up. You know,
I get it. Totally. I think that's, uh,
that's where, where I am at the
moment, you know? Um, but yeah.
What,
uh,
what topic would you speak about if you
had to give a Ted talk on something that
you're not known for at all? So it
can't be, can't, can't be tutoring,
can't be tennis,
can't be tenants,
can't certainly can't be the
writing that you're doing.
It might be on things that make people
laugh because I've done all these studies.
Because when, when you're
writing, you want to,
you want to get to the sense of what
makes kids laugh, right? Because as,
as horrific as a school for getting
evil books are at times or they're quite
dark, they're also, they're
also quite funny. Um,
and a lot of it is trying to find
out what, what makes kids laugh.
And so I would do a Ted talk.
I would, I would hope on this,
I read this book or this study about,
you know,
these people who spent like 10 years
trying to figure out what makes people of
all cultures laugh no matter what.
Like even if you go to the
recesses of the Amazon,
it'll make people laugh and they came up
with four things and before things were
okay were there,
try not to die laughing while I say this,
number one is beating someone
with a kitchen utensil.
Got It. Good. Good to know. Okay.
Number two is falling down
a short flight of stairs,
which apparently no matter where you are,
it makes people laugh.
Number three is, um, a swift fart
delivered in silos going to say far,
it has to be,
and there somewhere,
which as I like us was a swift
fart delivered in silence.
That could also be the name of my memoir.
And I use that.
I use that in chapter three of the first
book and it's always mentioned as one
of the kids' favorite moments.
And I'm like, of course,
because it's one of the four, four
things and number four is number four.
It was such a shock. And then, um,
it stayed with me is
adults dressed as twins.
What adults dresses?
Twins.
If you parade two adults dressed in the
same clothes in front of a weird tribe
in the middle of the Amazon,
everyone will laugh.
All right, that would make a good
ted talk because I just think,
I think things like that, like what
connects everybody, right? What are,
what are the common denominators?
I just think those are important.
And so I'm trying to get to the bottom
of those cause that's what fairytales are
also, right? That's at the end of the day,
school for getting evil at
their core are our fairytale.
So I'm trying to get to
the be essential Nis of,
and maybe this is why I'm so focused
on Zen and meditation and trying to
understand the world beyond the matrix
of trying to get to the bottom of like
what connects every kid, what
connects every one of us,
you know, before are blank.
Slates are filled. Definitely.
What is, what is the
bad advice that you hear
given out often in your world?
And I'm deliberately keeping that very,
very
broad. Not going to define your world for
you. You can take it any way you want.
I think when people say,
you know,
this whole idea of like following
your passion, right? Following what,
what you think you are meant to do or,
or following what you love,
I don't always know is going to
lead you somewhere productive.
Because I think ultimately what you are
meant to do isn't necessarily what you
love. It's, it's um, what you're good at.
It's what you were divinely meant to do,
what you're good at.
And I always think that's the
better question. What do you,
what are you better at than anyone else
in the whole world? What would you,
what would you put yourself against
anyone else in the whole world against,
you know, at, um,
and I think that's what's going to lead
you somewhere really good following,
you know, cause what everybody
wants to be, you know, uh,
a professional athlete or movie
star at some level. So I dunno,
following what you love or your passion
is necessarily going to guide you to the
most fulfilling career. Well,
I think it's also easier,
let's see,
easier in the sense that there are more
options for taking something you are
good at and,
and molding it into something you can
be excited about or combining it with
other things that you are excited about.
Then starting with an undirected passion
and then trying to become good at
wherever that leads you. Oh, you're
right. You're right. You're 100% right.
Because if you're just following
the passion, you don't have the,
whatever it is,
the 10,000 hours that is,
that is behind mastery even right
now. Get going. Yeah.
If you could have one gigantic billboard
anywhere with anything on it, you know,
short message, no advertising.
Uh, what would you,
what would you put on it?
A message to get out to the world?
I think one of two things. One is
if I'm in New York, it would be, um,
death is coming. You know,
I'm, one of the things I'm,
I meditate on a lot is just
what it would feel like to die.
That's the other thing. Oh,
besides that, looking for the me,
some days I just try to imagine what it
would feel like for everything to just
disappear first, the something of
consciousness to become nothing.
So actually trying to experience death.
Um,
and I think that has led me more towards
happiness than anything else in my life
is so like trying to understand that
your life is short and it's going to end
and it can end at any minute. So
take advantage, right? Really,
really try to make of your life
everything you can, you know?
So that's the one thing. And
then the second one is, um,
when I'm in Miami because my parents have
a beach house on this island and it's
so clear,
uh,
above that you can see that this
sort of night sky with the stars.
And so if I was anywhere else
but New York, I would just say,
look at the stars cause you can't see
stars and in New York because every time
you look up there, you realize the
fact that there's life on earth.
It's such a weird freak accident
that should never have happened.
And there is no meaning to life
necessarily in the larger cosmic scheme of
things. It's just a
fluke. It's an accident.
So enjoy it because
the fact that you know,
you got to have a life in the first
place compared to the sort of infinity of
the universe is, um,
it's pretty remarkable.
I like that.
And it,
it surprisingly echoes the
thoughts of two very disparate
people I've had on the podcast. Also, Bj
Miller, who's a palliative care physician,
helps people to die in hospice care.
And Ed Cooke who is a,
a memory champion and
entrepreneur from the UK.
Both talk about the
stars in a similar way.
So I think that is a profound
place to start. To wrap up,
just a few more questions and then I'll
certainly ask at the very end where
people can find you and so on.
But do you have any,
any ask or request or suggestion
for the audience? Any, any,
any parting words or
recommendations, suggestions, please.
I would just say that
I think, you know, if,
if these are sort of the principles
that you're interested in, uh,
not just for yourself
but for, for kids, um,
either your own or somebody else's.
I think this,
this book series well sort of lead those
kids in the right direction because it
forces them to question
all their assumptions about
what good and evil are, uh,
about what they usually see in
the world and about, you know,
what their life is going to look like.
And it's about, it's about empowering,
empowering kids.
When kids usually don't feel
empowered and usually feel, you know,
so, so helpless. So it lets them, um,
we interpret what heroes really are.
So I would just say, um, you know, uh,
give it to a kid and see what
their reaction is. So when,
thank you so much for the time.
This has been a blast. Awesome.
Say it would be great to grab some Mid
Majesty Tea when I'm next in New York or
you're next in San Francisco.
Where can people find you
online and learn more about you?
Say Hello on social if that's, uh, one
of the places to find you. Where, where,
where should they find you besides
Tinder? In, besides Tinder,
if only there were a search
function. Alas. Um, let's,
uh, you know, I think Twitter, um,
I tend to post very
regularly Instagram as well.
And then we have our youtube channel,
which is called ever, never TV,
but that's mainly for, for
the kids. So Twitter and
Instagram for the adults, Eben,
every ever,
never TD for the kids.
And also the school for good and
evil website is a treasure trove. Um,
for any kid under the age of, of 16 of
just even if they haven't read the books,
it's just a great place to,
to spend some time because there's so many
awesome interactive features on there.
Twitter, it's at Soman
Chin Nani, right? Shania.
Am I getting that right chain on it yet?
So I'm [inaudible] on Twitter and
then Instagram is Soman see. Got It.
So m a n c.
Well so thank you so
much for taking the time.
I really enjoyed this conversation and
to everybody listening you can find links
to everything the school for good
and evil. Of course. Everything else,
all the books you mentioned, all the
docs we mentioned in the show notes,
which can be found with the
show notes for every other
episode@fourhourworkweekdotcomforwardslashpodcastallspelledoutforourworkweek.com
forward slash podcast and as
always and until next time,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Fridays,
a very short email where
I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the, uh, the
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com
that's four work week.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and
you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many, many years.
I absolutely love audio books and they
are one of my favorite ways to pass the
time when I travel.
I'm on the road all the time in audible
allows me to consume many more books
than I possibly could otherwise I have
to audio books to recommend right off the
bat.
The first is perhaps my favorite audio
book of all time and it's the only audio
book I've wanted to listen to twice in a
row. The graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
It's amazing and you will thank me.
There are a few different versions.
I like the version that
we'll narrates himself,
one of the most soothing
voices of all time.
The second book is vagabonding by Rolf
Potts Pott s which had a huge impact on
my life and formed the basis for a lot
of what would later become the four hour
workweek,
so go to audible.com forward slash Tim
and you can choose one of these two books
or any of many, many other options
that could be books, magazines,
and much more as a listener
of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can also access a free 30 day trial.
Just go to audible.com forward
slash Tim you can't make more time,
but you can make the most of it.
So turn your travel or your commute
into something more with a free trial at
audible.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim to
start now and get your free 30 day trial.
This episode is brought
to you by trunk club.
There are two types of men out there.
You know who you are,
guides who love shopping for
clothes for a short on time,
category A and those of you who hate it,
category B,
I am in the latter category.
My fashion sense is also
probably somewhere between
homeless and confused with a
dash of lazy added in.
Either way.
You can take heart and I've used trunk
club now and have found some of my
favorite pieces of clothing that make me
look a lot better than I would be able
to handle on my own and there
are many reasons for that,
but you can get clothing that fits
perfectly and looks amazing without ever
stepping into a store. Again, thanks
to trunk club and they make it very,
very easy and the clothing's
handpicked by a personal stylist,
your own personal stylist.
All you have to have you do is go to trow
club.com forward slash Tim typing your
measurements,
share your likes and dislikes.
They'll pick your clothes from more than
80 top brands and ship them right to
your door. You keep what you like,
you send back what you don't.
If you don't like any of it and
sent it all back, it doesn't matter.
And Trunk Club is not
a subscription service.
This is what appealed to
me among many other things.
I didn't want to constantly be getting
dinged by things or have to deal with the
headache of constantly getting boxes.
It's not a subscription service.
Shipping is always free and you have
five days to try on the clothes.
So a couple of points here.
Number one,
get started today. Go to trunk club.com
forward slash. Tim, try it out.
You get premium, close expert
advice, no work, no risk.
That is a winning Combo.
And I have found some of my favorite
espadrilles shoes from them. Bright Green.
Uh, I do like the color
green and they actually work.
I've had so many compliments on the
shoes and more people ask me where I got
them to.
Any other pair of shoes I've ever had
and more shirts I kept ended up keeping
about. I would say three quarters of
my box, which I did not expect to do.
So go to trunk club.com forward
slash Tim and check it out.